et nous allons écrire notre invité
politique représentante des républicains
cette année c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont
rejoint bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous à nier c'est vrai le député
européen vice présidents des républiques
alors on le voyait les républicains sont
loin derrière la nuque et la majorité
présidentielle quatrième derrière le
rassemblement national vous pourriez
perdre la moitié de vos députés votre
ancrage territorial n'a pas suffi bien
sûr que si vous savez on a subi un
accident industriel avec la
présidentielle et un score très faible
4,5 pour cent et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
logique institutionnelle qui veut qu'on
donne une majorité un président élu
aurait élu pour agir et donc évidemment
on est victime de ce fait majoritaire
mais toutefois on nous a à plusieurs
reprises publié notre acte de décès et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que notre
groupe peut être un groupe charnière à
l'assemblée nationale ait joué un rôle
extrêmement important pour faire avancer
les réformes dont le pays a besoin donc
je trouve qu'au contraire la droite à
résister elle a résisté alors qu' on
aurait pu éventuellement avoir un groupe
tellement minime qu'on aurait pu
disparaître un enjeu c'était la survie
de la droite vraiment et donc avait
craint cette disparition oui oui on va
être très honnête je pense que le
résultat de quatre et demi pour un parti
qui est héritier de gaulle qui a donné
cinq présidents la france qui a gouverné
la france et qui a dominé la vème
république oui il y avait un enjeu de
survie de la droite et donc moi j'essaie
j'avoue j'ai poussé un ouf de
soulagement quand j'ai vu des résultats
et je pense très sincèrement qu'on peut
avoir un groupe de 70 députés à
l'assemblée nationale parce que là on
est encore à la mi temps on va re
mobiliser notre électorat en leur disant
une chose très simple seul vote utile
c'est le vote ait l'air dimanche si vous
croyez en la justice en la police en la
construction européenne à toutes les
questions de pouvoir d'achat sur
lesquels nous allons travailler au sein
de l'assemblée nationale alors dès
dimanche votée et l'air alors vous
évoqué la possibilité que le groupe ait
l'air soit un groupe charnière dont la
future configuration de l'assemblée
nationale ça prendrait quelle forme est
exactement on commence à se traduire
écouter on n'est pas dans une opposition
pablo viennent on n'est pas non plus une
force d'appoint l'objectif c'est de
travailler avec intelligence sur tous
les textes dont nous pensons qu'ils vont
dans l'intérêt national sur la réforme
des retraites sur les questions de
pouvoir d'achat sur les questions de
sécurité en fait travailler sur tous les
angles morts du quinquennat pour obliger
le président à entendre son opposition
on a bien vu sur des sujets importants
comme la taxe carbone ou les 80 km/heure
en avait le sentiment que les députés
n'étaient pas suffisamment connecté au
terrain pour entendre les remonter les
préoccupations des français sur ces
sujets là nous avons la chance d'avoir
des vrais relais locaux qui pourraient
utilement faire remonter les
préoccupations et donc je le redis on
n'a pas forcément les mêmes visions sur
le pouvoir d'achat par exemple le
pouvoir d'achat beaucoup de mesures qui
ont été proposées sont dans une logique
court termiste et dans l'urgence nous
nous voudrions des mesures pérennes
comme l'augmentation des revenus du
travail par exemple il faudrait
augmenter leurs revenus du travail en
baissant la csg nous proposons également
la conversion des rtt en salaire l'a10
fiscalisation des heures supplémentaires
sans plafond
même les mesures qui seront présentées
au moins là-bas si elles vont dans le
sens de l'intérêt général évidemment il
faut arrêter de penser qu'on sera dans
une opposition tables vides alors que
christian jacob lui même avait dit que
j'étais pouvoir d'achat en juillet pour
vous elles sont pas suffisantes on a
compris mais elles sont les bonnes si ce
sont des mesures pérennes oui parce que
la politique du chèque à un moment donné
ça coûte très très cher et ça ne va pas
très loin pour juste pour être clair
vous seriez dans l'optique d'un soutien
un peu au coup par coup ou est ce que
vous envisagez la possibilité d'un
accord de gouvernement d'une forme de
pacte non écoute et on a un comité
stratégique tout à l'heure je ne pense
pas je pense qu'on est dans l'idée d'un
groupe indépendant et dans l'idée d'une
opposition utile et non papa bleus
viennent parce que quand on voit qu'il
va y avoir la nuque qui sera dans un
rôle toujours très outrancier je pense
que notre pays qui va connaître des
moments difficiles dans les mois à venir
a besoin d'une assemblée nationale
apaisé et j'allais dire qu'on vous l'a
dit guy giva pas apaisé l'assemblée
nationale ah non quand on entend les
déclarations de jean luc mélenchon a
l'impression que ça va être la
révolution aux perpétuelles et que on se
demande s'ils vont pas faire plus de
bruit dans la provocation savez nous à
la limite qu'on soit 50 ou 80 peu
importe ce n'est pas tant le nombre
c'est le poids politique et d'avoir des
députés qui vont bosser qui seront
enracinée qui sont véritablement utile
c'est ça qui compte les deux
circonscriptions pardon quels moyens de
circonscription que vous avez regardez
c'est la circonscription de l'ain dans
la qualité candidats damien abad votre
ancien président de groupe damien abad
qui arrive en tête il est en duel face à
la nuque le candidat des républicains
est éliminée est ce que vous appeler à
voter danard baddou second tour et coûté
très clairement alors on a nous un
comité stratégique comme je le disais
tout à l'heure la position sera prise
évidemment par le parti mais moi à titre
personnel entre un candidat de la nuque
et un candidat macro évidemment je vote
candidats macron parce que encore une
fois je crois en la justice je crois en
la police je crois en l'état de droit et
que donc je ne mets pas sur un même plan
la nuque et et un candidat dit manuel
mata est ce que vous n'avez pas un
risque de déboussoler un peu vos
électeurs parce que vous avez eu un peu
de mal à vous différencier de la
majorité présidentielle pendant ses 5
ans et là vous vous appeler à voter pour
les candidats ensemble face à la nuque
vous et vous expliquez vous allez voter
au coup par coup s'agit certaines
réformes d'emmanuel ma team personnel ça
c'est ce titre personnel mais encore une
fois c'est parti qui décidera cet
après-midi ce qu il ya un risque avoue
dissoudre dans cette majorité
présidentielle on va pas du tout se
dissoudre la preuve c'est que on va
avoir un groupe indépendant comme je le
disais mais qui sera une opposition
utile on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'élus enracinés on a la chance d'avoir
un groupe qui sera sans doute le
deuxième groupe de l'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale il n'est pas
question de se dissoudre ne se confondre
dans le maquereau nisme parce que encore
une fois ces deux visions de la société
différente si on prend le sujet du
régalien c'est un des angles morts du
quinquennat et sur les question
d'autorité nous nous avons un boulevard
s'est encore une fois je leur dise sur
la question des retraites sur la
question d'autorité sur les question
d'école nous voulons nous être un
aiguillon du gouvernement mais est ce
que vous avez donné une position très
claire vous la
multinationale est ce que vous souhaitez
que christian jacob clarifie aussi la
situation car il a dit pas une voie pour
les extraits seulement est ce que il
doit dire la république en marche ce
n'est pas la même chose que la nuque et
que leur assemblée nationale et danses
actuelles on venant par exemple c'est
vrai qu'il faut faire attention à ne pas
tomber non plus dans le piège tendu par
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui les choses
sont très claires emmanuel macron spurs
souhaitent une force centrale unique
face au populisme d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite et que les résultats
c'est que le message qui est envoyé aux
français et dramatique se dire qu'en
gros si vous ne soutenez pas la
politique d' emmanuel macron alors vous
avez le choix entre marine le pen entre
jean luc mélenchon et c'est un message
qui je trouve est extrêmement dangereux
parce que demain l'alternance désespéré
ce ne sera pas les extrêmes qu'ils
incarneront mais la droite républicaine
et donc notre famille politique doit
justement travaillé à préparer
l'alternance de demain et cette
alternance elle se prépare aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale avec un groupe
important et qui encore une fois je le
redis sera indépendant mais dans une
opposition utile et intelligente vous
avez dit que c'est un peu la survie des
républicains qui étaient en jeu lors de
ce scrutin
comment on va se jouer sur quoi va se
jouer la reconstruction de votre parti
comment est-ce que vous analysez ce
résultat du premier tour par rapport à
cette question là écoutez d'abord je
trouve que c'est une bonne première
étape positive nous devons honnêtement
tout refaire du sol au plafond nous
allons un problème de ligne et un
problème d'incarnation après ce qui
arrive c'est en regardant les résultats
de ce premier tour non non je vous ai
pas réfléchi c'est pas comme ça le
lendemain d'une inhumation peut décider
vous voyez dans le sud est par exemple
c'est un bastion des républicains le sud
est et les alpes maritimes le var le
vaucluse lattes dans le var et le
vaucluse a aucun candidat dlr au
deuxième tour oui il ya quelques même
dans les alpes-maritimes vos candidats
sur mon message strictement rien dire
que c'est impossible à rennes ces peines
quand les fixes et ça ne veut rien dire
parce qu'encore une fois c'est un fait
majoritaire et des députés ne fait pas
résisté à une vague il ya eu une vague
et on ne résiste pas à la vague et puis
vous savez il ya un an tu as de la
guérenne au niveau national je parlais
d'une vague du de macro mais qui fait
que la nuque entre la nuque bleue et
rennes fait qu'en fait les nerfs on est
et on a fait quatre et demi pour cent
donc à partir du moment où on n'est pas
dans cette recomposition
évidemment certains nos députés ans
ont été victimes mais
ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
d'essayer de clarifier notre ligne
idéologique parce que c'est vrai que
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas réussi à
jallais pas dire unir mais à réunir les
trois droites des trois courants de la
droite la droite bonapartiste orléaniste
et légitimistes et ensuite nous devons
avoir un un vrai leader j'allais dire un
leader naturel et nous n'avons pas il
faut aussi le dire pour essayer
justement de réunir ces trois droites
donc une feuille sur laquelle ligne est
ce qu'à un moment il va pas falloir
arrêter de vouloir réconcilier trois
droites qui sont absolument sûrs et
console et c'est un vrai sujet vous avez
raison c'est un vrai sujet on vous
n'excluez pas une recomposition de la
droite à l'issue de ce scrutin a bien
sûr que si justement une recomposition
de la droite mais sûrement une récession
c'est-à-dire un éclatement si vous
voulez dire les choses différemment ont
coûté une partie de la droite qui
rejoindrait peut-être reconquête ou
génération je ne pense pas du tout la
preuve encore une fois c'est qu'on va
avoir un groupe important à l'assemblée
ce qui se joue maintenant c'est notre
unité et notre cohésion si nous restons
unis
cohérent avec comment dire nos
propositions pour faire avancer le pays
je ne pense pas bien au contraire vous
savez il ya une étude et la fondapol qui
récemment montrait qu'on fait nos idées
de droite sont majoritaires en france
même si nos scores sont très faibles
donc les idées de la droite ne se sont
pas évaporés avec nos défaites même si
c'est vrai qu'elle a été épuisante donc
nous allons évidemment nous
repositionner encore une fois je le
redis sur notre ligne sur notre
incarnation sur notre organisation sur
le renouvellement aussi parce que ça
compte également et aujourd'hui avec ce
nouveau député qui vont être réélu c'est
la première étape de la refondation et
un dernier mot dans les résultats d'hier
on l'a vu julien baer est éliminée dès
le premier tour aurélien pradié fait lui
un très gros score dans le lot est ce
que c'est aussi un peu la présidence de
votre partie qui s'est jouée hier et ce
qu aurélien pradié à une longueur
d'avancé
aurélien pradié bon il était déjà
secrétaire général donc oui fait partie
des talents de la droite qui sont amenés
à jouer un rôle important dans la
refondation bien sûr mais l'a pas prise
longueur d'avancé pour la présidence
mais tous les candidats ne sont pas
encore
officiellement candidat donc voila merci
année c'est vrai merci beaucoup d'avoir
réalisé notre rêve tôt ce matin
[Musique]